what's going on people today we finally
got some new information about part
three of Attack on Titan the final
season uh specifically we got this brand
new poster but we didn't get a release
date
um now when the uh when part three was
announced back in like may I think it
was we already knew that it was coming
out in 2023 so that isn't any new
information what we really wanted to
know is if it's coming out in in Winter
because if you guys remember part one
came out in December of 2020 and part
two came out in January of 2022 so if
they were going to follow that same
pattern of you know December or January
then you'd expect that today we would
have got a a trailer of some kind right
but no all we got is this poster so I'm
gonna guess that yeah we're not getting
it next month in December we're probably
not getting it in January my best guess
and this is purely a guess for me but I
would assume it would be like April time
onwards
um if it's any earlier than that then we
probably would have got a trailer by now
in terms of the poster itself though
it's pretty interesting um it's meant to
parallel the uh the volume cover for
volume 33 of the manga except for I
guess you have I guess the slight
difference is that you have Reiner in
this poster here whereas he wasn't in
the uh the the volume cover and also it
looks more cinematic as well like the
Flames behind Aaron the way the the wind
is kind of like sucking them in or the
steam it's pretty cool it looks very
cinematic you remember how we were
speculating for a while that they might
do a movie to wrap up the series if they
were doing that this is like a movie
level poster I think it just looks epic
like compared to the previous poster
that we had um for the part three this
one is is a lot more a lot more
intimidating I think
um and in terms of the small details
there's no hanji which is interesting
um if you flip Levi around so obviously
he's upside down here but if you flip
him around you can just tell that he's
like you know he's in fight mode ready
to kill kill Aaron basically
um and yeah everyone just looks like
they're being sucked in towards him I
guess I guess I was intentional it's
meant to be like a metaphor maybe about
how like Aaron has uh the actions he's
taken is like kind of like LED everyone
to this point where they have no choice
but to confront him and attack him
besides that there's not really much
else to say about this person it looks
good
um now in terms of what the official
account is saying on Twitter
um if if I hit the translate button it
says Aaron who was turned into a Titan
is confronted by those who used to be
his companions scheduled to broadcast in
2023 please continue to wait for further
information such as broadcast
information
so that's basically them saying that
they're not ready to give the release
date just yet
but when they do I will be making a
video then to update you guys with all
the information
um and feel free to let me know in the
comments your thoughts on this poster
um I personally like it a lot I know a
lot of people don't like it because all
I have to do is look under the comments
of of the Tweet when this was first
released a lot of people were not liking
this but um no I think it's really good
to be honest I think it's pretty good
um but yeah that was all I had to say
for now
um new video coming today or tomorrow
about chainsaw man so stick around for
that and um yeah until the next one
peace out